>> Greg: TONIGHT FNC IS
HOSTING A TOWN HALL WITH
BERNIE SANDERS.
I WASN'T INVITED SO I GUESS I'M
OUT OF TOWN.
IF I HAD AN HOUR WITH OUR
LEADING THREE-MINUTE SOCIALIST,
I WOULD ASK IF YOU HAD TO TEACH
A COURSE ON MARXISM OR LENINISM,
HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS THE
100 MILLION PLUS DEAD THEY LEFT
BEHIND?
WHAT CAUSED IT BEHIND
ADMINISTRATIVE ERROR?
SOCIALIST BRING UP SUCCESSES IN
EUROPE WITHOUT MENTIONING THE
ECONOMIC GROWTH IS MISERABLE
COMPARED WITH THE UNITED STATES.
WHY HIDE IT?
YOU LIVE IN THE GREATEST
ECONOMIC SYSTEM IN HISTORY THAT
YOU SEE IN SOCIALISM SYSTEM
REJECTED BY NEARLY EVERY NATION
THAT HAS TRIED IT.
DO YOU SEE EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY AND EQUALITY OF
OUTCOME IS THE SAME THING?
SHOULD THERE HAVE BEEN A CAP ON
BOOK ROYALTIES WHICH MADE YOU A
MILLIONAIRE?
COULD YOU ONLY HAVE ONE HOME
INSTEAD OF THREE?
CAN YOU GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY THAT EXISTS
AFTER YOU FACTOR IN AGE,
EXPERIENCE, EDUCATION?
OLDER PEOPLE TEND TO HAVE HIGHER
INCOMES AND MORE WEALTH.
YOU ARE OLDER AND RICHER THAN
MOST.
AREN'T YOU PROOF OF ECONOMIC
MOBILITY, NOT INEQUALITY?
SINCE YOU BECAME A MILLIONAIRE,
YOU'VE TRAINED YOUR SITES ON
BILLIONAIRES.
THERE ARE 585 OF THEM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IF WE TOOK THEIR MONEY, WOULD
OUR PROBLEMS BE SOLVED?
IT'S BEEN SAID IF YOU ARE NOT A
LIBERAL WHEN YOU'RE YOUNG YOU
HAVE NO HEART BUT IF YOU AREN'T
A CONSERVATIVE WHEN YOU'RE OLD,
YOU HAVE NO BRAIN.
WHAT'S YOUR EXCUSE?
JOINING US NOW ARE BRET BAIER
AND MARTHA MacCALLUM.
THEY ARE MODERATING TONIGHT'S
TOWN HALL WITH BERNIE SANDERS.
I THINK IT WENT PRETTY SOFT ON
BERNIE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Bret: WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
HAVE YOU HERE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
ONE THROUGH FIVE SOUNDS GOOD TO
US.
SPEAK TWO DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
THOSE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
TONIGHT.
>> Bret: SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: LET'S GO AROUND THE
HORN.
>> Dana: I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT THE LOCATION BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S SUPER INTERESTING
THAT WHERE YOU ARE, THERE WAS A
13-POINT SWING.
OBAMA VOTERS IN 2012 BUT BY 13
POINTS, TRUMP MOTORS IN 2016.
CURIOUS, I'M SURE GOING TO ASK,
IF BERNIE SANDERS THINKS
DISTRICTS LIKE THOSE THAT HE
THINKS HE CAN FLIP BACK.
>> Bret: I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS HE'S DOING THIS.
PENNSYLVANIA HAS ONE OF THE
SWING -IEST STATES.
THERE ARE MANY TRUMP VOTERS WHO
SWITCHED.
THEY WERE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND
THEY WENT TO TRUMP IN 2016 AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
HE'S HERE.
>> Martha: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
VOTERS WHO WERE BERNIE
SUPPORTERS IN THE PRIMARY
PROCESS, 11 OR 12% OF THEM ENDED
UP BUILDING UP FOR
HILLARY CLINTON BUT FOR
DONALD TRUMP, NOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THESE ARE THE AREAS THAT HE
NEEDS TO COME TO.
IT'S POLITICALLY ASTUTE OF HIM
TO KNOW THIS IS WHERE HE NEEDS
TO BE IF HE WANTS TO FLIP THOSE
VOTERS IN PLACES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Donna: HEY, BRET, AS YOU
KNOW SENATOR SANDERS RAN ON
TRADE IN 2016 AND HE HAS CALLED
THE PRESIDENT'S POLICY IS WEAK
LABOR PROTECTIONS.
WOULD LEAVE ASKING TONIGHT WHY
THE PRESIDENTS TRADE POLICIES
ARE WEAKER THAN THE POLICIES
HE'S PUSHING INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY?
>> Bret: TRADE IS DEFINITELY A
TOPIC THAT WILL COME UP, DONNA.
IT'S KEY TO THIS REGION.
WE ARE IN THE SHADOW OF
BETHLEHEM STEEL, PLANTS THAT
CLOSED DOWN IN 1995.
THIS AREA WAS DEVASTATED WHEN HE
DID.
IT'S A KEY ISSUE FOR VOTERS HERE
AND THROUGHOUT REALLY THIS
ENTIRE REGION.
YOU LOOK AT THOSE STATES,
MICHIGAN, PENNSYLVANIA,
WISCONSIN, OHIO.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE
BATTLEGROUND FOR 2020, AS YOU
LOOK AT THE MAP NOW.
>> Martha: A LOT OF THOSE
PEOPLE ARE THE CATEGORY THAT
WERE LOOKED UPON AS THE
FORGOTTEN VOTERS AND BOTH
BERNIE SANDERS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO TAP
INTO THAT AND WHAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM BERNIE SANDERS IS THAT HE
BELIEVES THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
FAILED THOSE FORGOTTEN VOTERS.
DO THE VOTERS FEEL THAT WAY?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BIG THE B
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BIG THE G
QUESTION.
>> Greg: IF YOU ARE STAYING AT
THE BETHLEHEM HOTEL, THERE IS A
PICTURE OF ME IN THE BAR.
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHY IT'S THERE.
I THINK YOU DID STOP BY AND HAVE
A DRINK.
STAY SIX I AM SURE THEY ARE
GOING TO DO THAT, GREG.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
BERNIE SANDERS.
I THINK THE FACT THAT HE'S DOING
THIS FOX NEWS TOWN HALL THIS
EARLY IN THE RACE AND WHILE HE'S
THE TOP MANY OF THE POLLS SHOWS
A LOT OF POLITICAL INTELLIGENCE
BECAUSE HE'S SIGNALING TO HIS
COMPETITORS THAT I'M NOT HERE TO
HIT SOFTBALLS AND HE IS SHOWING
HE HAS A GENERAL ELECTION
MIND-SET.
HE'S GOING TO LOOK FOR AS MANY
VOTERS WHEREVER THEY ARE AND TO
AS WIDE OF AN AUDIENCE AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LISTEN TO
ANY OF MY QUESTIONS BECAUSE
YOU'VE PROBABLY GOT THEM NAILED
DOWN BUT ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE A
MOMENT, LIKE THE BOXERS OR
BRIEFS QUESTION OR SOMETHING?
ASK HIM ABOUT TIGER WOODS OR
"GAME OF THRONES" OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
>> Martha: IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU THINK WE SHOULD ASK?
SHOULD WE ASK BERNIE SANDERS
ABOUT BOXERS OR BRIEFS?
>> Jesse: NOT BERNIE.
IS THERE GOING TO BE QUESTION
WHERE IT GOES, EVERYONE WANTS TO
KNOW ABOUT A POP CULTURE
SCENARIO?
>> Martha: I THINK IF WE
SHARED IT WITH YOU NOW IT MIGHT
RUIN THE MOMENT.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE LIKELY TO
DO THAT.
STICK AROUND AND WATCH.
>> Lawrence: THERE IS A NEW
POLL OUT THAT SAYS BERNIE IS
TAKING THE LEAD.
WILL YOU PRESS HIM ON THIS?
IS THERE A GROWING SUPPORT FOR
HIM AND WHY?
>> Bret: YEAH, I THINK IN
ALMOST EVERY POLL, HE IS IN THE
LEAD AS A DECLARED CANDIDATE.
WE KNOW THAT VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS NOT YET IN AND HE LEADS
MANY POLLS.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THINK OF THE EVOLUTION HERE FROM
THE OUTSIDER WHO WAS PRESSING
HILLARY CLINTON AND CAME VERY
CLOSE TO NOW THE FRONT RUNNER
WHO HAS THE MOST MONEY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD AND IS GETTING
THE BIGGEST GROUND AND IN SOME
POLLS HE'S LEADING AND IS
LEADING AS A DECLARED CANDIDATE.
>> Martha: I DON'T THINK THE
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZS OF THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW WOULD EXIST OR
BE AS EXCEPTED AS THEY ARE IF IT
WEREN'T FOR THE GROUND THAT
BERNIE SANDERS LAY DOWN.
HIS STORY IS EXTRAORDINARY
BECAUSE HE'S FORCED TO
CONVERSATION IN AMERICA THAT I
NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD LIVE TO
SEE, WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD BE
A CAPITALIST OR SOCIALIST NATION
AND THAT'S A QUESTION THAT IS
VERY FUNDAMENTAL TO WHERE WE ARE
IN THIS RACE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S AN INTERESTING PLACE TO BE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
WE ARE PROBABLY MINUTES AWAY
FROM GETTING BERNIE SANDERS' TAX
RETURNS FOR TEN YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY PUT IT OUT
30 MINUTES BEFORE THE TOWN HALL
BUT WE'LL HAVE IT.
>> Martha: START LOOKING IT